22 winners all underage 20 $100,000 to
drop out of school and pursue our dreams
this is team Technorati
he rocks his name's Stan Stan the t-rex
pool and beach volleyball court
via Google meeting the engineers
actually behind these Crocs that we use
daily whether people who mail glass
search is an amazing chance and so who
here has ever tried on glass this glass
is gonna sit above your eye you're gonna
be swiping forwards swiping backwards
swiping down and then you'll be able to
look around the website and scroll
around that way oh yeah you have to
think about the philosophy of Google
accents about doing things ten times a
hundred times the next step
car accidents huge problem right a lot
of people are gonna in car accidents
what does Google do they create a car
that drives itself take the human aspect
out of it what are you guys think about
it when you first heard about it I have
terrible visual effects absolutely
horrific I mean worse than my Mosteller
I met my content my glasses like this
thing and putting this thing I was
immediately within 10-15 seconds
actually kind of painful to look at this
is the feedback we want but but really
the reality is that everything starts
off large and tiny I feel like the
function I can really tired out in other
applications first before going here and
once before people are really coming
from with that larger technology this
would just fall people like why isn't in
our faces yet I've never thought that
way so it was great to try Moodle class
I think that idea of 10x thinking of
going a few steps ahead of where you
actually are really pushing technologies
is amazing but that doesn't mean I'm
gonna stop questioning
you're going to hop into a 10x thinking
workshop and think about your projects
and think about how we can 10x them
we're going to teach you the process
that we try to follow so there are three
fellows that we're gonna be helping out
today my challenge is how might we help
healthcare consumers find the best
option for themselves how can we reduce
the gap between what we would consider a
virtual experience and a real experience
how might we make data analysis easier
inaccessible to laymen let's split up
and pick a challenge per table
gamestorming starts with big-picture
thinking can we do it by just fitting
like a bunch of like having a lot of
data and testing it out the important
part is tying it into what the way men
wouldn't understand so most most people
if they saw a giant excel file so brain
writing is one activity that we do often
you're gonna write one idea about how
you might solve this problem per post-it
last 30 seconds take a post-it that
isn't your own said you can cause
difficulties if you were broken they
call navel specific struck with a bevel
that's for like doc - is to have like
doc X and doc X out could you should get
fatter doctor I don't know now what I
want you to do is just by yourself
storyboard one idea builds out in six to
eight different ways this step is where
the prototyping comes in when we
actually build something I is the first
step of this because we've got a
toothbrush here that's supposed to
detect like the acidity in your teeth
from within tracking and aggregating
that you create technologies that
actually read you know certain metrics
about your body each day
so that can represent the data monster
and this is a winged angel the heli will
solve the problem hopefully you got a
little bit of an idea of how Google X
thinks of moonshot thinking and 10x
thinking and thinking a little crazy
they I would assume that they have
something against mining just because
didn't it just keep scrolling up just
like the drop box oh yeah I love that we
can be this kind of inter collaborative
group of people Aidan's words not only
further in our own endeavors and
pursuits but also making sure we help
each other I've already been able to
make some strides and how I'm thinking
about my part to how thinking about hive
just by living with a few of the other
fellows and thinking about that scale
into two years is really unbelievable
the value is is tune in for the next
episode of team Technorati
when we get an insider's look at the
tech shop and be sure to subscribe to
the wired Channel